[Title Card]
Hello guys, Greg Alba over here.
I'm pretty sick right now
I..I got a lot of symptoms and that's why this video
coming out late.
I feel
a little decent right now
So I'm like, alright now's the time to film this.
Uh, the immediate prequel to episode 4, directed by
Gareth Edwards who did Godzilla and Monsters.
So, I already sold on that. I know Donnie Yen's in it
And I love the Ip Man movies, or the I P man?
And I still don't know, if I should call him Ip Man or
I P man.
Woah.
Looks...
Looks just like it.
Nice they even got the old sound effects.
I rebel
Katniss Everdeen
Shit
Oh it's clear
Oh its an alarm, thought I was gettin electric guitar.
Woah. Forest Whitaker's in this. What.
Nice
Wow, dude, this looks so cool!
I think it looks awesome man.
I...I think it looks really cool
Uh, I'm sure their gonna be some crap this film
gonna get. Like a ...
I didn't realize that
Felicity Jones was the star of this movie.
Like the, main lead.
I guess Star Wars is into this thing now
Where they
cast young, British female leads.
Oh boy, woop.
Feeling that sickness coming back
I thought the trailer relieved it.
Wooh.
No, but some obvious things that I
really liked from it
Uh, the tone,
I think is really cool.
This movie has a similar dark tone.
Its like, their's a lot of
Star Wars nostalgia in there.
But, I like that they're taking a more
dark, realistic approach.
I don't know about, realistic, the right word, but
Its a darker approach for sure.
Now, in this can out of Star wars movies,
Is it a film that's "milking" the franchise?
I don't know.
I can't tell yet if it's truly a necessary prequel.
Regardless, though,
it looks just cool a step back into the Star Wars world
of the 70's.
Although you know, like
one weird thing that I got,
and this is not a big bother for me,
It does kind of feel like a
young adult novel, in a way
cause you got this young woman
rebellious and she has to lead the rebellion.
and you know,
there's some Hunger Games touches
to there, for sure.
I feel like some people will
automatically have a problem with that
because already,
Oh my god, of course,
you're gonna clean your leaves at this hour.
Cause I know people when they hear
the word,"young adult"
they already like start getting mad
because they hate the whole concept of
what a young adult novel is.
There are some definite similarities here.
Although, this looks like
it could be one of the better versions
of a young women being rebellious
She's British again.
You know like
we already got that with Rey.
ah, but
its not a problem
they're both very good looking women.
I would gladly watch them on screen
cause of how hot they are
and the fact that they're tough
meaning
BDSM possibly.
And i'm just really excited to see
Donnie Yen in this trailer
you know i'm glad they showed him in the trailer
because a lot of people love the
Ip Man movies.
Like I said, don't know if its
I P man or Ip man
But in the movies it sounds like they were saying Ip man.
But you know, they show him fighting
with a bow
finding the Stormtroopers
Um,
I got a joke.
maybe he asks
uh
to fight ten stormtroopers.
*finger snap*
just a little, uh,
Easter egg joke for ya.
I think Forest Whitaker is really
cool. I don't know if people are gonna
feel about Forest Whitaker being in Star Wars movies
I don't
don't know why I said it like
they might have a problem
but
Forest Whitaker is a great fuckin actor
and its cool to see an academy award winning
actor in this fucking film.
I don't know if he's playing
the villian or not
either way cause
I know Darth Vader suppose to be in here
And a lot of people want the Darth Vader
from the Rogue Squadron stories.
You know I like the way he moves
in the video games
like where he's so fucking fast
and just
terrifying force.
ah, force.
But I just love how everything here
looks like legit Star Wars
you know
the Storm troopers have those helmets,
the ships, the uniforms.
One thing i'm hoping for though
is storm troopers have strong reputation
for missing their shots.
A lot.
And if this is like
the Rogue team vs. the Storm Troopers
I'm really hoping the Storm Troopers are
better at shooting in this movie.
Not saying its exactly that plot
i'm just saying when the
Storm Troopers are there
I would like for them to improve on that.
And I know Darth Vaders in it
but remembering
where Episode 4 started off
with a story of the Jedi's.
I don't imagine
will get Jedi's in this film
excluding the Sith
of
you know
Darth Vader
The red lightsaber might be the only
lightsaber we see in this film.
But regardless
it looks fucking cool
I like the tone I love the director
Everything from what i'm seeing
looks just like a really interesting
picture.
It really feels like they're
challenging themselves to do
something different.
Ah.
That's it okay.
Now
I know we haven't seen
Vader just yet
but at one minute and twelve seconds
it looks like that could possibly
be Darth Vader rocking
his bitch ass robe.
Thats my theory
Anyway guys
thanks for tuning into the channel
trailer made me feel a little bit better
Uh, if your new to this channel
subscribe today, become a Reject
and, uh,
follow us on our social networks
like Facebook, Instagram, Twitter
and, uh,
i'm gonna go throw up now
Thank you.